from new york with tonight's show  starring johnny carter  and now here's fabulous harry potter  father here you go  wait a minute harry belafonte hosted a  week of the tonight show  what what how did i not know this harry  belafonte takes an existing  white institution and he turns it into  something that represents  his world there are many sides to harry  belafonte  singer actor activist harry had an  agenda and he had the people to back it  out  what do you have in store for us this  summer i feel  that we are in the midst of the most  critical period in our nation you see  how pivotal this week was that was the  most  revolutionary move that mainstream  television  could have done at the time  good night  you